lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la relación entre el binario
binario que es el sistema numérico base
2 base 2 quiero explorar la relación
entre el binario
y el hexadecimal
ex a ver si mal que es el sistema
numérico base 16 hace 16 ahora la razón
por la que esto es muy interesante es
porque 16 es una potencia de 2 y como
vamos a ver prácticamente podemos pensar
en el sistema hexadecimal como una
representación condensada del sistema
binario ahora como ya he dicho creo que
bastante el sistema binario se utiliza
muchísimo en todas las ciencias de la
computación y en la ingeniería de la
computación y en todo lo que tenga que
ver con computadoras el sistema binario
es lo que está de fondo es la
representación que se utiliza cuando
hablan de puertas lógicas y de
transistores y de todo ese tipo de cosas
pero el sistema extra 10a también
aparecen un montón porque en realidad si
es como una representación condensada
del sistema binario
a qué me refiero con eso voy es vamos a
escribir un número en binario entonces
escribimos algún número en
representación binaria a ver vamos a
poner 1 0 1 1 0 1 1 1 0
ok y podemos poner aquí entre paréntesis
y sino que está en binario y ahora te va
a tocar ponerle pausa y tratar de
convertirlo directamente a su
representación en el sistema numérico
hexadecimal pero te voy a dar una pista
antes ok
piensa en esta representación cuál es el
lugar de los 16 es y cuál es el lugar de
los 256 es voy a suponer que ya lo
intentaste la cosa divertida de pasar de
binario a hexadecimal es que no tienes
que pasar por el sistema decimal bueno
en realidad para hacer cualquier cambio
de base entre cualesquiera dos bases
tampoco tienes que pasar por diez pero
en este caso en especial es muy sencillo
acá y lo único que tenemos que pensar es
cuáles de estos lugares son potencias de
16 a ver por aquí este es el lugar de
los unos el lugar de los unos este es el
lugar de los dos es de los cuatros de
los ochos y hasta acá está el lugar de
los dieciséis es entonces todos estos
lugares de aquí podríamos pensar que es
el lugar de los unos del sistema base 16
ok porque con estos cuatro lugares
podemos contar desde el 0 hasta el 15
poniendo puros unos y todos los números
de 0 a 15 en el sistema hexadecimal son
puros unos entonces con estos cuatro
lugares podemos contar del 0 al 15
aunque déjame en lugar de poner a 15 en
el sistema decimal vamos a escribirlo en
el sistema extra decimal donde es una
efe
estos cuatro lugares cuentan desde cero
hasta efe y son los unos del sistema
hexadecimal ok las unidades ahora este
es el lugar de los 16 es y podemos tener
entre 0 y 15 osea f-16 es porque si
tuviéramos 16 o más 16 es entonces ya
tendríamos más de 256 y tendríamos que
agregar otra cifra en el sistema de
extradición al ok pero una vez más estos
cuatro lugares cuentan en total cuantos
16 es vamos a tener en el sistema extra
decimal y luego llegamos a el lugar de
los 256 es y bueno aquí en este número
binario nada más estamos ocupando una
cifra pero por aquí a la izquierda hay
otros tres lugares que determinen
cuantos 256 6 tenemos ok y podemos tener
en 3
efe 256 6 y así nos podemos seguir hacia
la izquierda todo lo que queramos y como
si esto hubiera sido una pista te digo
que vuelvas a ponerle pausa al vídeo y
piensas y ahora es más fácil escribir a
este número en el sistema de extra
decimal bueno suponiendo que lo volviste
a intentar ahora si vamos directamente
al grano aquí en estos cuatro lugares
estamos contando entre 0 y 15 unos o
unidades
entonces vamos a ver exactamente cuántas
unidades tenemos por aquí este es el
lugar de los ochos así es que tenemos
que sumar un 8 14 y un 28 más cuatro son
12 más 2 14 así es que tenemos 14 pero
el 14 en el sistema hexadecimal se
escribe como
ahora veamos cuántos 16 es tenemos este
es el lugar de los cuatros y este es el
lugar de los doce entonces tenemos 426
así es que tenemos 6 16 y finalmente
cuántos 256 es tenemos pues nada más
tenemos 1 entonces tenemos un 256 y
bueno podemos poner por aquí que esto
está en el sistema hexadecimal y listo
este número binario en el sistema
hexadecimal se escribe como 16
y también podríamos inventarle un nombre
basado en el sistema extra vecinal por
ejemplo a ver qué te parece si esto se
llama 1 256 116 y 6 y bueno está muy
confuso verdad también podríamos
llamarle g a 16 y entonces esto sería un
250 y 616
creo que hay que seguir pensando en esto
de los nombres ahora si tienes muchas
ganas de saber exactamente qué número
son estos sientes esa necesidad de saber
cómo se llama en el sistema que se
adecua a la cantidad de dedos que tienes
en la mano entonces escribe este número
en sistema decimal aunque no está que
realmente no lo necesitamos